what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss this
absolutely insane development in the one
piece story we are discussing the full
translator pages today of the new
one-piece chapter and wow it is not an
exaggeration to say this is the biggest
chapter of one piece yet and there are
plenty more details that were not in the
spoilers that we're going to cover so
make sure to stay tuned for this one if
you enjoyed these one-piece reviews i
want to keep them coming chilla parking
within and smash that like button
smashing his parking energy and passing
his scared of rochi energy if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one-piece videos and updates and
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all this chapter is
called warrior of liberation obviously
referring to luffy who awakened last
chapter and was at once identified as
joyboy and sun god nika we hear luffy's
voice saying how can i still stand
what's happening i just lost but i feel
like i'm having a blast and then he
laughs clearly since he says he just
lost this is still luffy and not an
instance of joy boy taking over his body
and personality which is a relief we
want luffy to stay luffy as he beats
kaido or else it wouldn't really be
satisfying and it wouldn't really mean
much we jumped to momo telling yamato
that luffy is joy boy then we see sanji
kid la hyogoro and marco sensing that
luffy is still alive so although oda
teased that luffy's voice disappeared
and joy boyz appeared last chapter to
make it seem like maybe joy boy took
over this is in fact luffy at the same
time as it is joy boy as well aka luffy
is joy boy joy boy doesn't need to take
over luffy it's going to see nami
bawling her eyes out with tama as they
react to the news that luffy is still
alive nami clearly cares a lot for luffy
and that's been emphasized quite a bit
recently and i gotta say i see them
ending up together if luffy ends up with
anyone that is at least as goal d roger
did i can see luffy leaving behind the
kid and that could very well be with
nami but anyways i'm getting ahead of
myself we jumped to the five elders it's
mentioned that they sacrificed one of
their best agents and enraged kaido so
they're wondering do they really have
their priorities straight obviously one
of them questions whether luffy is worth
all the trouble and it's mentioned that
it's better than the alternative they
gotta snuff out something that important
obviously they were aware of luffy's
potential as the sun god and they were
trying to prevent it again makes you
wonder what pirate shanks was talking
about with them since they clearly
didn't seem as focused on this before
that conversation don't get me wrong i
love shanks but it's quite the
coincidence we're told no matter the era
the world government has always failed
to acquire the gomu gomu fruit even
after 800 years of trying it's almost as
if the fruit is evading them and it's
mentioned that that's not impossible
since all zone fruits have a will of
their own and this one carries the name
of a god that's all insanely hype and
interesting the fact that luffy has a
god fruit of course but also the
distinction that zones are the only ones
that have a will of their own according
to this it makes me wonder how much of
the chopper we know is the original
reindeer and how much is the will of the
human human fruit is it possible as
current personality is based more on the
fruit than the original reindeer
interesting implications to consider for
all zones anyways back to the real name
of luffy's fruit it is a mythical one as
i always hoped for and its name is the
human human fruit model nika so the sun
god nika fruit pretty much insane stuff
and i personally think that human human
fruits and their different models should
in theory have the strongest wills of
all zoned fruits since usually other
animals are associated more with
instincts than free will but at this
point i admit that's just speculation we
see luffy jumping through the sky
looking like the sun god silhouette
we've seen before as the moon frames his
own smiling silhouette we're told the
nikkei user's body gains the properties
of rubber and combat they're supposedly
only limited by their imagination
putting smiles on faces far and wide
they're the embodiment of the warrior
liberation so clearly rubber still is an
important aspect of luffy's powers even
if more abilities will be added on top
of it despite the name change in the
fruit he can arguably still be called a
rubber person but the really crazy line
is and i quote they're supposedly only
limited by their imagination end quote
now i think it's not far-fetched to say
that luffy probably has the most
overpowered fruit now but that line that
i just singled out makes it sound almost
too broken if he's only limited by
imagination then he could potentially do
anything with his fruit manifest any
ability but we'll see what happens
clearly these five elders are drawing
from legend and not just fact so it'll
be interesting to see how luffy uses the
powers going forward we're told that
awakening exponentially strengthens the
user's rubbery body and they have even
more freedom it is allegedly the most
ridiculous power in the world so yeah
everyone wishing that luffy's fruit
wasn't special it's actually the most
special but that's okay in my book since
luffy in my view was never set up as an
underdog in the way that naruto was in
the beginning for example he was
impressive and kicking butt from anime
episode 1 so i don't feel as tricked
when the story continues to build up his
specialness and they did it well too
because it's not like everyone who got
this most special of fruits awakened it
luffy was the first in 800 years so he
still had to put in the work to make it
this special we finally get the revenge
of hiyori against orochi odin's foolish
dancing is mentioned again and it hurts
every time they remind me he already
mentions how they didn't honor the
secret agreement of riwano but to me it
was so obvious they wouldn't what kind
of war ended because of five long years
of dancing i respect characters who have
honor and keep their words but those
characters can't expect others to be the
same way odin even underwent the boiling
for an hour challenge only for them to
kill him anyways we get some really
heartwarming moments like kid hiyori
crying because of what people said about
her dad and whether that bothers him or
not and he said with a smile of course
he's fine with what other people say
since he has and i quote you guys aka
his family so wholesome so sweet that
kid hiri lighted up when she heard this
saying then she swears she'll always be
here for him then finally hiri's mask
comes off revealing the anger pain and
tears she tells the pleading orochi to
hold his miserable wretched tongue and
proclaim she is kozuki hiyori she says
orochi never had honor and orochi
carries on to beg for his life fittingly
hiyori doesn't even have to kill him
since he sowed his own demise kundro's
flame comes back and instead of going
after hiri burns orochi instead and
hopefully this time he stays gone hiri
with tears in her eyes says the dawn
will come some great revenge and closure
there for her and orochi obviously
deserved everything he got it's a well
executed revenge scene for a very
hateable character by oda back to luffy
who feels like anything is possible now
he can keep fighting a bit longer and
his heartbeat sounds funny so
interesting that he is hinting at a time
limit there since he does stay a bit
longer meaning this power isn't
necessarily as bottomless as it may have
appeared at first nevertheless luffy
says this is his peak his gear fifth we
got gear 5 boys and an awakening and
luffy became a pirate sun god i don't
know what else we could have asked for
oda over delivered if anything here
kaido looks panicked by something on the
roof and we see a giant hand come down
and grab kaido's dragon body as if he
were an ordinary snake or something
luffy pulls him up so fast that kaido's
eyes pop out of his head like in the old
cartoons and this cartoonishness really
becomes a part of luffy's awakened power
as we'll see his muscles suddenly become
cartoonishly big like popeye on steroids
and he swings kaido slams him on the
ground again and again luffy is laughing
all the while kaido realizes it's luffy
and instead of being angry he says he's
grateful luffy is alive clearly as i've
been saying it's not all about winning
for him and despite what he says
sometimes he doesn't want to win in a
dishonorable way doing so against odin
really messed with him and it continues
to haunt him to this day even though
he's messed up he clearly has more
redeeming qualities than orochi kaido
launches a blast breath luffy's eyes pop
out like kaidos did a little while
before he rubberizes the ground raises
it uses it to reflect kaido's attack
back at him it hits luffy laughs and we
get an official gear 5 announcement
slash label and it can't be denied
luffy's hair is very reminiscent of
super saiyan hair and the white color in
the manga and the sun theme of this form
suggests that it will most likely be
blonde as well kaido is still alright
and says sorry about that idiot from
before i didn't want to win like that
and luffy says don't sweat it now let's
finish this these dudes are completely
talking like equals now and i love it
it's a far cry from when kaido looked
down on luffy of course let's mention
luffy's interesting curvy eyebrows that
many have compared to sanji's then
there's the eyes or pupils which now
have a ring around them and have been
compared to mihawk and even emu's eyes
although to be fair i do think he's
missing one more ring for that unless
the outer rings are just drawn too close
together to distinguish them well but
we'll see how much the changing eyebrows
and pupils end up meaning either way as
we're told the battle reaches this
finale and we can assume it won't take
long now for luffy to beat kaido and
probably take on the biggest bounty
we've ever seen in the history of one
piece not only would he have earned it
by all of his exploits up to this point
and by beating the strongest creature in
the world but the fact that he has the
most dangerous fruit on top of that
means it's probably going to be raised
even more after he beats kaido the
strongest creature in the world i could
see only the fast-growing blackbeard and
the marine slash world government giving
him significant trouble we are pretty
much at the end game here something i'm
really curious about is luffy saying
this is my peak this is a shonen and i
assume luffy will get stronger if it's
only by getting more used to gear 5th
but crazy to see that luffy said he's at
his peak i look forward to seeing the
implications of that statement being
fleshed out of course it could mean my
peak at this moment but it feels more
significant than that it might be oda's
way of saying that luffy won't get any
new forms obviously sun god luffy was
mvp this chapter and let me know how do
you think kaido will fare against this
new luffy will luffy overpower him
quickly now or will kaido still put up a
significant challenge this battle
between two epic mythical zones will be
insane no doubt but yeah that is it for
this one if you did enjoy the one piece
video i want to keep them coming you
know what to do chiller parking within
and smash that like button with no mercy
smashing that like button is parking
energy and passing is scared of rochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one-piece playlist that includes videos
on all the yonko warlords supernova
admirals all mythical zone users and
much more linked to that it's in the
description and until next time see you
space cowboys